su médico realizará una dilatación y
raspado también conocido como dice por
sus siglas en inglés para quitar el
tejido del interior del útero el útero
es un órgano reproductivo muscular en el
abdomen inferior la parte inferior del
útero llamada cuello uterino conecta la
vagina con el útero
se puede llevar a cabo un dice de
diagnóstico para investigar la causa de
las siguientes afecciones sangrado
anormal o abundante dolor menstrual
severo dificultad para quedar embarazada
o células anormales encontradas en un
frotis de papanicolaou se puede realizar
una dice terapéutico para tratar ciertas
afecciones uterinas como sangrado
excesivo de los restos de la placenta
posterior al nacimiento pólipos en el
cuello del útero y pólipos uterinos
tumores fibroides que son tumores
benignos formados en la pared uterina y
aborto espontáneo incompleto o aborto
provocado en el que las partes del
embrión o feto o tejidos asociados
permanecen en el útero
es posible que el médico prefiera que
comience el proceso de dilatación el día
anterior al procedimiento si fuera así
el médico colocará una barra delgada
llamada laminaria en el cuello uterino o
una medicación para ablandar el mismo
la laminaria se expande lentamente al
absorber el líquido del cuello uterino
lo que hace que el cuello del útero se
abra
durante el procedimiento usted
permanecerá acostada boca arriba con las
piernas ubicadas en los estribos como lo
haría para un examen pélvico normal
recibir anestesia local o general
su médico insertará un espéculo en la
vagina para ensanchar el canal vaginal y
poder ver el cuello uterino
durante la dilatación el médico
insertará una serie de varas lisas en la
abertura del cuello uterino cada vara
será reubicada con una vara levemente
más gruesa de ese modo la apertura del
cuello uterino se ensancha o dilata
lentamente a fin de poder acceder al
interior del útero
una vez que el cuello uterino se ha
expandido a 6 o 9 milímetros
aproximadamente el médico puede realizar
una histerectomía un procedimiento en el
que se utilizan una pequeña luz y una
cámara para examinar el interior del
útero en busca de áreas anómalas luego
el médico realizará un raspado que es la
extracción quirúrgica de una parte o la
totalidad de la pared del útero llamado
endometrio
durante el raspado se insertará una
herramienta quirúrgica llamada cubeta
para quitar el tejido mediante raspado o
succión
si usted está siendo sometida a una dice
de diagnóstico el médico le quitará solo
una pequeña muestra del endometrio y lo
enviara al laboratorio para evaluarlo a
fin de detectar diferentes afecciones si
está siendo sometida a un ats
terapéutico
el médico extraerá el contenido completo
del útero para tratar una afección
uterina confirmada luego del
procedimiento la controlarán en una sala
de recuperación durante algunas horas
antes de regresar a su casa para
prevenir una infección no tenga
relaciones sexuales ni use tampones
durante dos semanas aproximadamente o
hasta que el médico le indique que es
seguro hacerlo debido a que su útero
necesitará generar una nueva pared es
posible que su próximo periodo menstrual
no ocurra de manera regular